let's get you to your takeaways we'll
start with a guy in flores brian flores
who has a history with new england miami
they've won five straight washington
they've won four straight how are they
putting these streaks together there in
washington and in miami
just you know both teams both both teams
or both coaches the players believe in
these guys you know they they just
believe in how hard ron rivera think
about ron rivera when
going through cancer
um the players saw all the sacrifices so
they love and they respect their coach
you think about brian flores if if they
didn't love and respect their coach at
one and seven they would have quit
they would quit but they've won what
five or six in a row they've been
outstanding they have a lot of respect
for brian flores and one thing about him
knowing him for my patriot days he's
going to continue to fight and claw to
get this team back on top so you know i
got a lot of respect for both the
washington football team and the
dolphins
you know ron revere and brian flores
getting his players to play for him
it's fun to watch tua play some of his
best football too right now because this
is starting to look like tua from
alabama he started to look comfortable
and confident back there and early in
his career he kind of had happy feet if
you know what i mean he'd be he'd have
someone open but he's sort of shuffling
his feet and now he's throwing it and it
throws all over the place like watch tom
brady play look how settled his feet are
look how tall he stands in that pocket
i'm starting to see tua play like that
now and the throws are starting to hit
and yeah he's athletic and he can he can
layer all of that on top of it but he's
finally starting to settle his feet when
you have receivers like waddle they have
great tight end play right there mike
kaseki is somebody who really leads that
charge for them so if he can just get
these guys the ball parker's another
playmaker on the outside this offense
has a little firepower and like you're
saying brian flores knows exactly what
he's doing defensively
absolutely in the impact of rookie wide
receiver jalen waddle he's giving his
offense some explosiveness that they
haven't had he's got the familiarity
with tua and like you said tua is
starting to look like a nfl quarterback
you told me that on sunday i said let me
pay a little bit more attention and
you're absolutely right
he's starting to look like he's playing
with confidence he's you know he's just
doing all the little things that it
takes to be a really good quarterback in
this league and we see with the defense
and with the weapons that they have on
offense just continue to incorporate
that run game to try to keep it a little
bit more balanced and they should be
okay
speaking of that run game i was having
fun going back and watching watching the
washington football team i just wanted
to go back and watch that game and
taylor heineke was taking some massive
shots i mean he was getting beat up back
there but what's fun to watch about him
is he pops right back up and he plays
just a true competitor he's just a pure
competitor they have an awesome run game
that offensive line is one of the most
underrated in the nfl to me leno jr
flowers sheriff lucas they're all
playing dominant football so four of
their five are extremely highly graded
on the offensive line and so when you
watch him play behind it when you watch
antonio gibson get going as a young
running back behind him all of a sudden
the washington football team even
without chase young is right back in the
thick of this playoff picture how do you
think they got here
well they got here through their head
coach his their head coach ron rivera
doesn't play he holds these guys
accountable and he'll let you know one
thing about ron i say he keeps it real
he's going to let you know what his
expectations are just like when he came
out and said i have no interest in cam
newton ron rivera is going to hold his
players accountable they respect him he
treats him like men and he is a certain
expectation level and if you meet it
you're going to be there if you don't
meet it you're going to be out the door
that's why i love them
that's right and then you got a guy like
heineken who throws just a bad
interception it was in the fourth
quarter the prior series he throws a bad
interception they get the ball back
they're down one there's two minutes and
22 seconds left and heineke still
believes he makes about five great
throws to get them back down the field
into field goal range they hit the game
winner so there's just starting to be a
belief and i'm with you that seems to
come from their head coach gets to your
second takeaway right here rob and your
second takeaway is with arizona the
cardinals they are back to full force
what'd you see with kyler returning
he gave them he definitely gave them a
spark i mean i think with his speed and
the decision making you could tell that
this is a completely different offense
there they it's just so much more
dangerous when you have colin murray
running around and you see with the
little um reception of d-hop in the end
zone they they still have that
connection but this is the guy that
really has impressed me james connor you
know and last year we thought he was
done with the pittsburgh stylist all
this guy can't play anymore but now you
give him some decent blocking you give
him a quarterback that can scramble you
give them a passing game now james
connor is a different guy and once we
talked about cala murray not trying to
do too much just taking the simple
things allowing his defense to fly
around and make plays four interceptions
three sacks a bunch of past breakups we
know buddha baker and chandler jones and
them guys they've been great this year
i'm with you i think what they did with
kyler was really smart to sit him with a
lower leg injury especially while
they're winning because they were
winning a couple of games right colt
mccoy's in there but they're still
finding ways to win if they're going to
really do something substantial this
year it's going to be with the healthy
kyler murray so they really took their
time getting him back getting him all
the way healthy that's what he looked
like i mean how many quarterbacks in the
nfl do you see that scare defensive
backs with their speed i mean you can
forget about defensive ends he gets
around them with no problem but
defensive backs don't know what to do
with them when he gets into the second
level and that's some scary scary speed
to me they are one of the big three when
i look at the nfc green bay tampa and
the cardinals those are my big three in
the nfc what's your take on those three
all in one group
i i agree with you boss i agree with you
arizona green bay and tampa bay you're
talking about
arguably you know with tampa bend and um
the green bay packers two of the best
quarterbacks in the league you got colin
murray there the most dangerous
quarterback in the league i think you're
spot on i i like those pigs but don't
sleep on tampa bay i'm telling you as
the defense gets a little healthier
they're going to come back and when and
at the end of the day they're going to
be right there
that's right let's get to your third
take away this one comes from sunday
night football ride the broncos they got
all those playmakers you were talking
about on the entire pregame show you
really like the receivers you like
javonte williams out of the backfield
but i'm gonna focus you in on the
quarterback and teddy bridgewater what
do you think of the most important
player
look man um i love teddy bridgewater we
know that he's a good kid he's been hurt
we cheered for him you know and
all those different things but at the
end of the day the broncos need another
quarterback they got to get them a
quarterback teddy bridgewater is an
average quarterback he's not going to
make a ton of mistakes but he's not
going to do a bunch of great things you
look at the weapons like you talked
about jerry judy in the slot you got two
receivers that are six three six four
big guys you got no offense and you're
throwing it directly to juan thornhill
and the defense i just don't get it
they're gonna have to find someone that
makes an impact there's nothing about
teddy bridgewater outside of his rehab
and everything that he's done you know
when he was injured that inspires me
when i'm on the field i don't see that i
don't see that fire i don't see anything
like that i like teddy bridgewater as a
person but at the end of the day if the
broncos want to win and utilize all the
money that they've invested in those
wide receivers you got jared judy you
draft in the first round you got javonte
williams as the running back you drafted
him in the second round you're gonna
have to get a quarterback that can play
this game at a high level and teddy
bridgewater can't
that's right and drew locke can't either
so like when you look at this team
they're playing good defense you got
javonte williams who was just carrying
defenses running the football we were
talking to tyra matthew after the game
how about the way he was talking about
javonte williams he's basically like
you're trying to get down there in
position to find him but by the time he
ducks underneath those offensive linemen
he's already so low you can't even get
leverage on him he had showed so much
respect for williams as a rookie which
was awesome to hear jerry judy's finally
healthy you were just talking about just
signed both of their other receivers in
sutton and patrick to contract extension
so they believe in everybody else the
defense has even been playing pretty
well without von miller but they just
can't find consistency at the
quarterback position and it's really
starting to hurt this team let's get to
your fourth one a quarterback who has
been very consistent tom brady starting
to look really dangerous and his man
gronk how about the way he's flying
around
gronk looks like he's been on tb-12
period he looks like he's 28 years old
like when i watch grunk play
it's like he's running smooth he's not
tight he's catching passes not only is
he catching passes he's catching passes
against linebackers safeties and
cornerbacks he's getting off the line
he's been healthy and tom sticks with
him i don't care if you get up there you
jam rob gronkowski a little bit he's
going to continue to fight and claw you
got to double team this guy especially
when they get in the red zone one guy
cannot stop him he's six seven 270
pounds and i don't understand what the
hell defensive coordinators are doing
how can this safety right here eric um i
forget his last name but he used to play
for the raiders you can't guard rob
gronkowski with this kid you can't it's
unfair it's not even right to ask him to
do something like that rob is one of the
greatest tight ends to ever play in the
history of football if i were a
defensive coordinator he would he would
get double team every single play he's
in the red zone he wouldn't catch a
pass that's right that's right this
looked like old times to me i mean it
it's crazy to watch gronk it'd be one
thing if he was sort of he's been a
league decade plus it'd be one thing if
he was out there looking like an old man
and kind of just having his last go
around in the league with brady or what
have you but i'm i'm right there with
you on the tb12 stuff i mean i haven't
seen gronk stride out like this since
about
2015 or something it's like i cannot
believe the way he's running if they can
figure out a way and maybe arrest him
maybe you just take him a game off maybe
you play him one week give him a week
off play him again be very strategic
about when you use him but if you can
get him through this full 18 week season
if you can get him to the playoffs i
don't see any reason why we i'm starting
to really believe we may be looking at a
tampa in a new england super bowl brady
belichick rematch can you imagine if we
got that one on nbc my goodness
did rodney harrison tell you that on
sundown i'm not sure i i think you might
have told me that like two months ago
rod to be perfect
forget about sunday but i'm gonna tell
you this for real what i think too
what's what's happened with tampa's
passing game is leonard fournette he's
actually making a difference i mean he's
catching a lot of passes out of the
backfield which has really opened up
opportunities for rob gronkowski because
as we see when we watch the tape he's
one-on-one no antonio brown means more
dependence on gronk so i think that tom
is tom is purposely coming out trying to
get ragrant the ball trying to continue
and have that that that chemistry that
continuity with him but i think it's
great man i'm so proud of rob gronkowski
the sacrifices that he's making for his
body so he can stay out there he can
play and you better believe he's on that
tb12 because he looks he looks good
i'm about to get on that tb12 here in a
second let's get you to your fifth
takeaway and i want to get some sound
involved here too so this is the ravens
the steelers right this whole rivalry
every time these two meet forget about
the record it's gonna be a great game
when they're on the field here was coach
tomlin though right after the game
talking about coach harbaugh and his use
of analytics this is fun listen to this
no
it did not you know they aggressively
play analytics
um and and so you know from that
standpoint they're predictable
you know what let me just say this i
don't really think it's analytics i just
think that coach harbaugh has a feel for
his team
and when he came out and said look we
don't have any quarterbacks i agree with
him you should go for it you got you got
mark andrews you got lamar you know
you've been down in this situation
before like
i don't blame him so
i don't think it's necessarily analytics
i just think that he had a feel for his
team i mean if they're dropping like
flies and you lost your best corner
marlin humphrey you lost a bunch of
other guys during the season like go for
it i'm not mad at harbaugh for going
four we were there early in the year
when they played against kansas city and
they won the game being aggressive you
know and this is this is all lamar right
here lamar has to he has to make that
play he has to make that play we've saw
it for two straight weeks lamar missing
easy passes throwing it to the defense
he's got to get back confident he's got
to step into that throw and anything
that mark andrews has hit his hands he's
caught the last two or three years so
lamar's gonna have to step up be able to
make these type of plays if they want to
continue to move forward
this is an easy play right yeah it's a
belief thing
right i'm with you he probably should
have dove for that definitely should
have had two hands out there on a fourth
down i mean you gotta put you gotta you
gotta go full extension after one like
that i would think and it wasn't i'm not
gonna question margaret i'm not gonna
question mark andrews i'm not gonna
question mark andrews with that
he's expecting the ball to be on the
money and when you throw the ball away
up here you can't reach forward because
he's he's running toward the sidelines
so i don't put that on
mark andrews i put that on lamar and we
like i told you the week before we
watched him throw how many interceptions
was it four
i think it was three in one quarter
three in the second quarter alone
right yep
yeah yeah so it's it's a belief thing
right and at some point the belief might
run out but the thing i remember from
the prior sunday night which i think was
the kansas city game was the
conversation that lamar had with tarball
where he basically just goes lamar do
you want to go for it i mean do you
remember that lamar said hell yeah i
want to go for it they they went right
back out there went for it and got it so
for me it's a belief thing but if you
stop getting them if you if you're not
able to hit that pass
the belief might start to go out a
little bit and i also think timeline
just wanted to get a little troll on the
back end because there's no doubt that
the ravens have been a team that on
fourth down especially fourth and short
they feel like they're built for it and
consistently they're going after it and
for the most part it's been great
results for them it just didn't work out
this time
and i look at defensively they lost
marlon humphrey their best defensive
back and it wasn't like he was having an
all-pro year or even a pro bowl year but
he's a guy that everybody looks to he's
getting paid a heck of a lot of money
and that's a huge huge loss for those
guys
let's see this afc playoff picture right
now that's a big loss for the baltimore
ravens that you just hit on so here's
how the playoffs currently sit nine and
four are the new england patriots they
already have that one seed in the afc
man that didn't take long so you still
got the titans hanging out there at the
two but that's a team that's very beat
up baltimore has played some sloppy
sloppy football but still found ways to
win those games late what's going
through your mind looking at this afc
playoff picture right now
i get excited when i see the patriots
okay
the chiefs and the coats those are the
teams like there's a lot going on with
the two or three seeds with the titans
and the ravens but when i look at the
coats the way they're running the ball
the way carson wentz is playing with
such confidence they got a good defense
the coats are a team that i wouldn't
want to play i wouldn't want to really
sneak up on the coach because they're
big they're physical they're offensive
line we talked about um
left guard quentin nelson getting
healthier it seems like he's starting to
play a little better
hey if if
if it's any of these teams i don't want
to play the coach in that run game
yeah i'm with you on that steelers still
lingering the other team that could get
interesting and they would have to get
healthy and i almost don't know how
healthy that baker mayfield can get
given just this slew of injuries that
he's battling through but their defense
to me looks really talented if baker in
this offense it's always going to be a
run dominant offense but if baker can
just get a little bit healthier and just
do enough in that passing game i mean
how good was miles garrett against the
ravens on that sunday night game that is
a very talented defense if baker can
just give him something at the
quarterback spot
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports